I am Sarah Jane Howe I went to Phillips
Exeter Academy Georgetown University in
Washington DC and also I had gone to
Swiss finishing school I'm pioneering
the etiquette industry in in China
geriatrician woman the matey town China
finishing school flourishes learning to
be a perfect lady who's fruitful Tricia
what half of Sean show you and the class
so this is me sitting in the front row
uh-huh very sure shiny good you're Swiss
finishing school many people are very
confused about what is a finishing
school and even a lot of media and a lot
of friends ask me they say oh you know
you need to teach your students not to
sit those are not my students the people
who were the overnight mushroom
millionaires they actually don't have an
interest in studying etiquette they're
just starting to buy the MS bag it is
sort of like the Maslow's hierarchy of
needs right it's the first eat food
shelter and only then afterwards respect
for others love you know honor etc the
way I see it my students were buying a
no-mess bag ten years ago and now
they're holding themselves to highest
standards so for them it's really about
cultivating refined taste a home in its
city Nadeshiko Falkor bernardo the gap
in path so it doesn't want me interested
outta me away or judges no I feel that
China needs us now this is my service to
the country how much is the course in
dollars the hostessing course for
married women is twelve full days and
it's sixteen thousand US dollars and
then the debutante course for unmarried
women is 10 full days and it's just
about thirteen thirteen thousand US
dollars it's not an insignificant amount
but everybody who's taken the class has
said it's worth every penny spent
I didn't just take the Swiss finishing
school curriculum and plunk it down here
I had to totally overhaul it for my
market so but when I added for the
Chinese market is pronunciation of
foreign luxury brands Ferragamo
introduction to expensive sports here
are Prince William and Prince Harry
you know intra saj showjumping you know
I myself am a passionate show jumper we
have costs such as napkin folding floral
arrangement personal styling dress codes
very nice but tricky Foods is one of the
favorite classes of the students
Johannesburg she could tricky food
sheekha foods a shoe na in high
dimensional Sueno IM baggage ha
Fonzie [ __ ] roll shabu car noise
Jonathan Jessup gun Julian shot in anger
Teta we are banded so it's that out it's
that bad choking you a woman Joshua
Amitabha Josh I'm athelia oh sure Fuu no
I think they're what the modern-day
Chinese woman is looking for today is a
guide because especially the hostess
generation their mothers grew up during
the Cultural Revolution so nobody could
teach them how to use a knife from a
fork and then their daughters are
totally westernized how to eat a banana
elegantly with a knife and fork CS
Young's other trail at home Rehana
do it coj kawaii
whoa-ho bye Jacob see shirt trigger
handle sure
hi I wish some of beer children your
shorts out Ted to show you easy I heard
wish him a full shebang question Willa
shoot Sammy Hagar's challenger to push
our contest you need drama woman tell
the butcher sure Tony Jay go woman go to
show off on me a nice meeting agenda
you